antoine bonjour le résultat de cette
élection at il été enterré par toutes
les parties
même si le président sortant a dénoncé
des irrégularités la transition devrait
malgré tout se faire en douceur il faut
dire que le résultat final où l'avait
évoqué avec près de 58% en faveur de
maya sendou est suffisamment large pour
que celui-ci reconnaisse sa défaite
écouté il y a eu un nombre sans
précédent de violations qui ne se sont
jamais produits tout au long des
campagnes électorales pendant toute la
période de l'indépendance
je n'appelle pas les gens à descendre
dans la rue
nous n'avons pas besoin de
déstabilisation la situation n'est déjà
pas facile du côté de moscou en a pris
acte de la victoire de la candidate
libérale dans la victoire de maya sand
ou vladimir poutine lui a envoyé un
télégramme de félicitations disant
espérer je cite le développement
constructif des relations entre la
russie et la moldavie
le porte parole du kremlin lui est
quelque peu entrer dans les détails
écouter le kremlin respecte le choix des
gens le choix des peuples et nous
respectons le choix du peuple moldave
bien sûr il faudra établir des relations
de travail avec le nouveau président de
la moldavie
nous espérons qu'elles seront mises en
place la russie apprécié ses relations
avec le choc le moldave
vous savez que la russie a toujours aidé
le dernier et en ce qui concerne nos
relations
elle devrait être fondée sur une base
mutuellement avantageuse en tenant
compte des intérêts des deux parties
nous savons que maya sans dout a déclaré
qu'elle travaillerait dans l'intérêt du
peuple moldave et nous sommes convaincus
qu'il est dans l'intérêt de ce dernier
d'établir des relations de coopération
est interaction bonne et étroite avec la
fédération de russie dans tous les
domaines
tomtom malgré le profil de la présidente
élus étiquetés pro européenne il n'est
pas dit que la politique étrangère de la
moldavie change radicalement
dans des déclarations faites avant
l'élection elle disait en effet vouloir
être pragmatique et tenter de se
rapprocher de l'union européenne d'un
côté tout en gardant de bonnes relations
avec moscou de l'autre merci beaucoup
pour cet éclairage entonne claireaux
depuis moscou